in just under an hour mass will be back
for thousands of employees here in clark
county
thanks for joining us i'm denise faldis
and i'm brian loftis this comes after
county leaders voted to require mass for
employees
in public indoor spaces now the goal is
to combat the recent covet 19
surge arko mana joining us now live on
the strip of why some workers are
worried about it
orca well denise and brian the new mass
requirements for
employees go into effect at midnight but
some workers are questioning how
effective it will actually be
since no it does not apply to customers
or visitors who are we protecting
that's the question robin mcdermott has
been asking herself since clark county
commissioners voted tuesday to require
masks for all
employees while indoors and public
spaces the nevada gaming control board
announcing the rules also apply to
gaming employees
it's very frustrating like i don't mind
wearing a mask
mcdermott works as a dealer at one of
the las vegas strip casinos and says
she's fine
following the rules but she believes
only mandating mass for workers does not
make sense
by having everybody that comes into the
casino
not having a mask on i think it's really
doing nothing
i don't think it will be very effective
but clark county commissioner justin
jones tells me it's a step in the right
direction
absent a mandate across the board
there's no way to constantly verify
who's actually vaccinated jones says
what we can do
is get vaccinated and follow the health
district's recommendation to wear masks
and doors
regardless of vaccination status and
when it comes to mitigation plans for
large venues
we're still working with our business
license team as to
what those should look like and how
we're going to do the review meanwhile
mcdermott hopes the mass requirement
becomes more uniform
i would like to see them have everybody
wear a mask if you go indoors
again the new mass requirement for
employees takes effect
at midnight and continues through august
17th at which point
the clark county commission board will
reevaluate and reconsider
and they are working with the health
district to try to determine benchmarks
to figure out how we can determine what
steps to take
at that point reporting live in las
vegas tonight orca mana 8 news now